I have a very interesting idea, but it's
it's a super complex move.
It's one of those moves that could end
up being a mistake,   but I
don't think it is.    Yeah,
this is such an interesting position.
Honestly, so rich.    Such
a rich position.
I can think about this for 30 minutes,
honestly, this position is so interesting.
And we'll, uh, unlock some of the secrets
after the game. I'm excited for this.
We are white
against Avela
vestida.   All right,
let's go e four,   as
we usually do,
we are once again facing a car
khan. You know what that means? We
get to play the fantasy again.
And we already have had the fantasy
twice in the speedrun. We've done a lot of
theoretical work in the fantasy. So by now,
if you've watched the speedrun diligently,
you should have a good sense of how to
play the fantasy. If I
remember correctly, both of our previous
opponents, they took on E four,
and then they both made the same mistake
with knight to F six. Kind of an
Alokine Karokan cross.
This time we are facing
a new move, knight to D seven. And I will
admit, I've never seen this move. This is
not considered a top theoretical
move. It's what I would call an inaccuracy.
Now, obviously, a move like this cannot be a
huge mistake. It's a developing move, but
it's a weird developing move. I mean, it's a
passive developing move, and black is not in
any way challenging our control of the
center. Essentially, black is giving us the
kind of position that we want,   and black
is going to get most likely a very solid
but incredibly passive
setup as a result. Now, we
have, I would say, two main
choices here. With white, we can close
the center immediately by playing
E four, e five,
and then how are such moves
often followed up? Well, if you play the
French with white, then you might know that
E five is often followed up with F four,
and then you bring your night out to F
three, and then you can further solidify
your center by playing, uh, c
three. And that does seem
incredibly like an incredibly good version
of of the French structure. And I'll show
you after the game    what
exactly I mean when I say
French structure. Like, if you're not a
night C three French player with white, you
might become confused when I refer to the
French structure, but you'll see what I
mean. So I really like e five here. I think
E five is the, is the, uh, way to try to
punish black for this move. The other
option, of course, is
to play knight C three, just a typical
developing move. But after night C three,
what, uh, bothers me a little bit is
the prospect of black taking on E
four and then striking at the
center with E five, which leads
to some very concrete play
that I'm not sure is
entirely palatable to us,
especially given the presence of the
alternative e five. So I like closing
it down. I also don't think we've had too
many of these closed positions in the speed
run, and I kind of want to give you a
broad overview of how to play
different types of positions. And of
course, as we all know, a lot of
players, they struggle with positions that
involve a closed center. They feel like
they don't know what plans to pursue. And
when the center is closed, it's very easy to
feel as though you're just kind of shuffling
your pieces aimlessly back and forth.
Hopefully, this game will kind of change
your mind in that regard. Closed center
positions can actually be some of the most
interesting that you get in chess because
they force you to play on the flanks. But
flank play can be some of the most beautiful
and tactical, uh, that you see in any
chess positions.   So
what are our next couple of moves going
to be? Well, most likely we are going to
solidify both
rungs of our pawn
chain. Right. I'm struggling to figure
out a way to refer to these pawns
individually, but we have a pond chain right
on d four and e five. So both links of the
pawn chain we are going to solidify with
other pawns to make it as robust
as possible. Why do we need to make it
robust? Because black is likely
to attack our pawn chain
with, uh, his own pawns. Right. So, for
example, in the French, you often
see the move c five. In fact, black may play
this move right now. That is why
we need c three. Black can also attack the
pawn chain from the other end with the move
f six. You also see that often in the
French, and that's why I like playing
f four. So c five
is on the board. This is
essentially a no brainer. We play c
three. We most certainly
do not want our pawn
chain to dissolve this early
in the game because we don't have any pieces
developed. And the only thing standing
between us and, like death is our pawn chain
in the center.   So we definitely
want to go c three. You might
wonder, well, isn't e five
already well defended? It is.
There is a second reason that we want to
play f four, and that is, of course,
to open up the natural
developing square for the g one
knight.   And the reason we want to
develop the knight to f three is that it
has no other good spots to go. If instead
we had developed the night to e two, that
would just be incredibly awkward, and it
would also close off the natural development
of the bishop   queen. C seven is a
bit of an odd move. I don't think it
accomplishes that much. Notice that it does
not really threaten c takes D four
because we can take back and the Bishop on C
One is protected by our
Queen. So I think we can continue
developing along the lines that I have
outlined, and we can do it from
several different orders. We can play Bishop
to D Three first if you want to prioritize
peace development.   Or we can
immediately play F four and then bring
our night out to F three. I like both
options.     I
generally lean toward
peace development first when
possible, especially because
we are technically
lagging in development. We haven't
developed any minor pieces yet. So
I do like the possibility
of bringing our Bishop out
first.   And we're also opening up the
further possibility of playing ni
G One to E two, which
I just mentioned is an awkward move. But
with the Bishop already
outside of its initial square, ni two
becomes a little bit more appealing to
me. We're trying to
play as flexibly as possible. Given that our
opponent isn't developing into
ambitious style, we're leaving open
many developmental possibilities. And I
largely think this is a matter of taste. I
like the look of Nike one to eat, too. If
you want to prioritize rapid development,
that's the way to do it. But if you want to
play in a maximally ambitious style and
get as much space as possible, then
we should go for my initial idea and play F
Four. But F four is the
more textbook approach to these types
of positions. So we're going to go for
F four. This is the more
kind of I want to take it to my
opponent type of move.
And I think when a lot of people
see this move, what you'll
notice is that the Bishop on C one
starts complaining like, hey, what about me?
Now I'm staring at my own pawn.
But, uh, the Bishop has plenty of space
to develop to E three
or even to D two. And
this is where I quote my phrase
about not every piece   having
to climb out Everest at one time. Bishop to
E three is an entirely serviceable
way of developing the Bishop. In fact,
on E three, the Bishop does a great
job supporting the pawn chain even
further. And we definitely want our pawn
chain to be incredibly
robust. But, uh, we'll cross that bridge
when we get there. Let's start with night F
three. Let's get our pieces out first, the
ones that we know where to go.
Yeah. Or
distribute the COVID vaccine night to F
597. So if you know anything
about the French, then you know
that usually this night in the French
travels to F five, where it
puts pressure, of course, on
the D four point. So you might be
tempted by the idea of G four.
But G four is way too
cavalier. We haven't developed enough pieces
to justify a move like that.
And G four is very bad because of
H Five classic positional
move. And   funnily
enough, the opposite effect is
reached. We play G four to cover the
f five square. But as a result, Black
gets a huge outpost on f five,
because after g four, h five, we cannot play
h three. That's the big problem. Black
takes on G. Four. And you often see this on
the other side of the board, where the rook
on h one is going to be hanging.  So
instead,    we have,
again, two options. We can castle
kingside, or we can
preemptively got our bishop to e three.
But what and what I like about that move
is that in response to knight, uh, f five,
our bishop can very nicely slide back to f
two. And I like that because
if we instead castle and
blackblaze night f five, our
bishop suddenly can't come out to e
three anymore. Is that the end of the world?
Absolutely not. In fact, in that position, g
four becomes a lot more appealing
because it comes with tempo. But
these minor subtleties, these minor
developmental details often
make a huge difference on the course of the
game without you even realizing it. So let's
go bishop e three   in night
f uh, five, we drop our bishop back to f
two.    And later,
that bishop from f two is, first
of all, serving a very important purpose of
overprotecting the D four pawn.
And indeed, that is what happens, but also
much, much later, that bishop has a
way toward infiltrating
Black's position, bishop h four and bishop f
six is a maneuver that you see
quite often, especially if Black fianceto is
their bishop on G seven. Okay, now we
continue developing. We castle.
Yeah. So the move h
five, again, is typical for
these structures. And I've used that phrase
a lot typical for these structures because
we do have a very typical type of French
structure where our opponent is
displaying knowledge of the sort of classic
ideas and the classic way to arrange the
ponds. But h five is an all honky dory.
Black is preventing g. Four. That is true,
but Black is creating major
weaknesses, as some of you are pointing out,
along the dark squares. In
particular,   notice that we have an
outpost on G five doesn't mean that we
should play ni G five here. We shouldn't.
Nike five allows Black to
trade and fill some of the holes.
But later on, that, uh, G five could be an
important transit point when we start
attacking the black king. The other thing
that we can do later on is take the knight
out of the equation and then
stick our dark squirt bishop on h four.
As I indicated earlier, that could
allow us to control all of the dark
squares on the kingside
with our queen. So an
idea that you see is actually queen D one to
e one, then the trade on f five
and then bishop h four. And after the trade,
our queen on h four will have access to a
lot of these juicy outposts on the
Kingside.  But, uh, we're jumping
the gun here because we haven't completed
our development. And with the center
closed, the one major
rule about
positions with a closed center is that you
can generally take more time
to do stuff than you would with
the center open. And that makes intuitive
sense, right, that the position doesn't
change that quickly when the center is
completely closed, especially when it's as
well defended as our center is M.
So night A three is a bit of a dead
end move after a six. Yeah,
you could be tempted by this maneuver night
A three, night B five. But I don't like it
because night A three, a ah, six. Like,
where is the night going to go? I think a
more robust way of developing here is and
beat a D two toward the center. And you
might say, well, where is the night going
from D two? Again? Nowhere. Nowhere yet.
But it is in the center,
and you never know when its services could
be required.    It's
a frankfurt airport move. That's exactly
right.
The other
thing to remember about closed
center positions is that, broadly speaking,
there are two types of plans.
There's a type of plan where we
attempt to position our
pieces in a certain way and then
rip the center open, blast it
open. And our hope in such a
scenario is that we have arranged
our pieces in a better way than our
opponent has in order to
prepare for the opening of the center. Like,
we prepare our pieces in
such a way that when the center opens
up, we are somehow better
equipped to handle the consequences than
our opponent is.
And one reason that may be the case
is if we have a big development advantage or
if our pieces are placed a lot
more actively when the center is closed.
The difference in piece activity may not be
all that felt right, because things are
closed up. And just the fact that a piece is
not very well developed might not be
imminently felt. But when the center
opens, you suddenly start realizing that all
of those disparities in peace activity
are actually important. And we, in this
very position with the white
pieces, have a very interesting
idea    that is
part of this category of plan where we
just blast the entire thing open
and we hope that our more active
pieces are going to be better equipped in
the resulting chaos
to
address the new problems of the position.
What am I thinking about? What does it even
mean here to open up the center? Well, what
I'm not talking about is D takes C five that
isn't that isn't really open the
center, because DC actually just
gives black a little bit more space,
and it allows black to contest the
dark squares in the center, particularly the
E three square.   Instead, I'm thinking
not about b four, b four. Black
can keep things closed with C four, but
instead about the move C four
ourselves   creating the pawn
box. And by creating the pawn box, we
are guaranteeing that one way or the other,
the center is going to open.
But we can play C four
immediately.  What we can also
do is eliminate black's only
active piece before playing C
four.   We can eliminate black's
only active piece and then go C
four and really try to pin
our hopes in the resulting position
on our incredibly active
pieces.   So bishop takes f
five is what I'm thinking about.
But I also really like the look of c
four,    because we can delay
bishop takes f five. We don't have to play
it immediately. We can play it a little
later.    Yeah, I actually like the
look of c four.    And
if black plays pawn takes D four, then
we can take the knight on f five.
You might look at this and think two things.
First of all, what about knight takes C
four? Yeah, knight takes d four is what I
was evaluating just now, and hopefully
that will happen. So I can show you my
considerations. I'm, uh, not positive, by
the way, that c four is the correct move.
Not at all. I have a feeling that it is. But
this is a largely intuitive determination. I
didn't do too much calculation here. A
second thought that you might be having is,
how do I know that we're not afraid of
losing b two? Well, first of all, losing b
two is almost never a problem when you're
castle to the other side of the board
unless you lose a bunch of other pawns. When
black takes B two, and I'm sure you've
blundered like that before, right? Where you
blunder b two, but then you also lose c
three. So you don't just lose one pawn. You
lose your whole queen side. Here, our queen
side is still very much intact. It's not
like black has anything to do with
our pawn cube. By taking on b two, queen
takes b two creates no threats, allows us to
consider to continue pursuing our agenda in
the center.   And
I'm going to have to prove it. Queen takes b
two on the board.    Okay, m,  let me think
for a second.
I have a very interesting
idea, but it's a super complex
move.   It's one of those
moves that could end up being a
mistake,   but I don't think it
is.    Yeah, this is such an
interesting position. Honestly. So rich.
Such a rich
position.    I can think about
this for 30 minutes. Honestly, this
position is so interesting. And we'll
unlock, uh,   some of the secrets after the
game. I'm excited for this. Let me share my
idea with you all.
Honestly, this is probably a
mistake. I think I know why it might be a
mistake, actually.
Wow. Incredible. Black has an incredible
response to the move. I was intending,
which, by the way, is queen to a four,
trying to get the other rook to be one in
order to trap the queen.  But
that is far from the only way in which we
can address this position. We don't need to
try to trap the queen. I think the queen is
untrappable here. We don't have enough
firepower on the queen side. So I think we
should instead continue our focus in
the center and continue trying to
blast the center open so that
we can exploit our
increased peace activity.
So let's start
by making a move that we know is
going to be good. We know this move is going
to be good. C takes d five, right? We need
to open up the center in order to do
that. That is why we played the move
c four, and now we take on d
five. Now, if black does not recapture, then
we can drive this pawn forward to d
six. And that looks
horrific for black, absolutely horrific.
So   black
will probably end up taking back on d five,
and we're going to have to speed up a little
bit here. We've got six minutes, so I'm
going to have to make a couple of moves,
likely without too much explanation.
So what
to do after e takes d five is the big
question.   Well, most of you should
be tempted by the prospect of
then taking the NF five, ruining
black's structure even further. And as
I said earlier, eliminating black's only
active piece, which right now is the NF
five. So you should be tempted
positionally by the move bishop takes f
five. Of course, giving away your control
over the light squares is a little bit
painful, but it might be a worthy price to
pay,   and I think it is a
worthy price to pay.    I
think that we should, in fact,
take the night while we still have a chance.
And now
we should complete
the opening of the center.
We should complete the opening of the center
by playing DC.
Okay, so we played CD, then we took
the night. Now we played DC, and now we
can say that the center is fully open,
which means we need to start looking for
tactics, right? We need to transition from
general positional thinking
where we can
luxuriously bring our pieces
out and play a little bit more slowly. Now
the center is wide open. Moreover,
black has not yet developed their queen
side. So we really need to step on the gas
pedal here, because only a couple of moves
is what stands between black and
full consolidation of his extra
pawn, which, let's not forget, we have given
away. We've given away a pond.
So there's a couple of moves that I think
are pretty good here. The move that
occurs to me intuitively, perhaps it
also occurs to you intuitively,
is bishop f two to d four, because what I'm
seeing there is that we're actually X raying
the rook. So Bishop D Four,
followed by E Six looks really,
really interesting as a discovery against
that rook. Further trying to blast open the
center. But Bishop D Four is also good as a
standalone move. It just brings the bishop
into the center. And that's just a priori, a
good thing.    So
I'm a simple player.
I identify something I like and we play it.
Also, we're down to six minutes, so we got
to play a little bit faster here.
So Bishop
D four, it hits the queen. Also, the queen
was starting to annoy me a little bit. It
was   hindering, uh,   our ability
to bring pieces to good squares.
Right, that queen on B two
definitely stops queen C two. Right.
It just sort of hangs over us. So let's get
it out of there.   So our opponent is
thinking about where to put their queen,
but our response to most moves
is going to be E Six.
Right? There's a lot of ideas and one of the
challenging things about surviving these
positions, I think our opponent is playing
this fantastically, by the way,
so far,   making us
work work to prove it.
The thing is, if we do not go E
Six, then Black is going to stick a knight
on E Six and somehow keep the center
close. So E Six at this
point is pretty automatic. And that, I
think, was a big mistake. That right there,
I think, might be the decisive mistake
because this allows us, and I'm going to
play this move without thinking, to take on
F Seven and drive the king out into the
open. And once the king is on F seven,
we definitely have the firepower to
exploit that.   F Six
was the only move there to survive. This is
going to be destruction, I think.
All right,   so there's
two moves here that I, like most of
you are probably tempted by. Knight
to e five. Check. That's one of them.
95. King e. Eight. Queen takes h
five. Check. Might seem like made, but it's
not. It's not checkmate yet. Uh, the king
escapes to D Eight, and in that
resulting position, unfortunately, the move
queen to F seven, which would have
forked the rook in the pawn, runs into
bishop E six   still
not over. There is another move in
this position, which is interesting. Knight
to g five. Check. Which leads to kind
of a variation of that line.
But ni g five. Check. Allows the additional
resource king to G six, trying to use
the king itself as a defender. We've talked
about that concept in a previous
speedrun. I still think White is a huge
attack there, but there's no reason for us
to overcomplicate things. Let's go
95.    Absolutely no reason for
us to do anything outlandishly
fancy.
Okay. Whoa. This
looks
totally
Karakiri.
And again, I don't see a need for
us here to reinvent the wheel.
The one pitfall I think is the move
rookie one, which perhaps a lot of you
are, uh, looking at and salivating at
its prospect. But remember, rookie one,
there's knight c five to e
four.   When you occupy an open
file, you can't assume
that Black is just going to move the king.
By the way, king d six. Everybody should see
that knight c four is a fork
against the queen and the king.
Anytime the king and the queen are in a
forkable spot, you have to think about that.
So there's no need for us to do anything of
that nature. I think the simplest move is
queen takes pawn, not because we win the
pawn back, that's not the reason, but
because we're trying to get the queen to f
seven. That is the reason. It just happens
to capture the pond. We would have played
that move even if it had not
captured upon.
Okay,   so we still
have some work to do.
Rook f eight was actually a very good move,
which makes our job
harder.    Now, queen g
six, check has to be calculated first and
foremost, bishop f
six.      And
then let me think for a second.
Can we find a crusher in that
position?    It's not as easy as it
appears.   Yeah, I do like knight
g six. That's my second candidate
move. I love the look of Nike g six
because it opens up the e file
and it targets an
important cog in Black's defensive
machine. That bishop on e seven is
handling a lot of the dark squares, which
otherwise would be ours for the taking.
So queen h six check
is tempting, but there's rook to f six,
that's an issue. And maybe in that
position, we could drive the
queen, I don't know, up to g
seven. And then queen g eight is a checkmate
threat.    That
does look winning. That looks like an
excellent way to play, by the way. OOH,
I love it. Queen h six, check. Because the
idea is to prevent bishop f six
credible.
I love it. Let's do it. Queen h ah. Six
check. Comparing checks, one
of the themes of this move,
not assuming that two similar
looking checks do the same thing.
Bishop f six here, of course, gives up the
rook on f eight.   The king has
nowhere to go. And what is the
purpose of driving the rook out to f six?
Well, there are two of them. The first is
that the rook is under the x ray of the
bishop. And don't forget that even when
you're attacking the king, you are very much
allowed to win material. I tell
this a lot to students.
There's a fixation when
people are attacking on trying to checkmate
the king. And you might think, well, that's
the only way that the attack is going to
succeed. But there's a whole category of
ideas that involve basically
using the weakness of your opponent's
king in order to win a
decisive amount of material when you're
attacking. You can just go for your
opponent's pieces sometimes.
And because your opponent is so
preoccupied with defending their king,
he has to put pieces on vulnerable
squares. That's why these combinations
happen.   Queen b four.
That's a good move.
That's the only move, I think,
to keep things relatively
protected.   Okay, let me think for a
second.    Queen GH
at King d six.   I'm
sure we have some sort of
a beautiful win.
Okay, night F three, I like a lot.
Yeah, I like the look of night F three.
We do have three
minutes, so we have to be a little bit
speedy here.   I love the
look of night F three because it
doesn't give away any advantages.   It
doesn't give away any advantages. In fact,
it prepares night G five   and it
protects the bishop in a very safe
way. So the other thing to remember
when you've got these types of positions,
and of course a very resilient
defender is going to make you work for every
little bit of the attack. But,
um, among most levels, your
opponent is going to collapse in a matter of
a couple of moves. What you have to remember
is that we haven't actually
sacrificed anything. Black just resigns
it's plus eleven in this position.
We haven't actually sacrificed
anything. And what I wanted to show
was that if Black plays a move like knight
to E four in order to take the
sting out of knights, e five, the top
computer move is actually an incredibly
quiet move that just brings a piece
into the attack. That's all this move
does. It also cuts off the king from
its potential escape route just to move
rook A to C one. These are the types of
moves that a lot of people are not
willing to make when they're attacking. And
yet they make all of the difference between
a win and a loss. In many cases,
successful attack, failed attack,
for instance. Bishop D seven,
we just go rook to C seven. And the
added presence of the rook
overwhelms Black's defensive abilities
here. The top
engine move is actually knight F seven
with queen to E five.
Checkmate.   Pretty
little concept there.
Everything's protected. And this is
completely one sided.   So
I've already presented a little bit of
fantasy theory in previous
videos.    Um, here
we're just going to focus on our opponent's
move because I've never seen it before, and
I really want to make sure that we responded
appropriately and I think we did.   So,
e five is the first big decision of the
game. E five.
Once again,
the reason I rejected NZ three was
because defe and
e five kind of
transposes into   a more
conventional position. And I wanted to
punish Black for playing 97
according to the engine after
de. White is a little bit better here,
but, uh, how lame would it have been to go
into an end game this quickly? In the
fantasy,
you can play like Bishop E
three,   and then Long Castle.
And White is pretty comfortable here, but
Black has a nice knight on E five, so I'm
far from convinced at this
idea.     So I think we played
correctly. I think E five is the way to
punish knight to D seven.
Now, I kept
repeating the term French structure. What
I mean is a structure that
primarily occurs in two different
variations of the French defense. One is the
advanced French. This is the classic e
five, c five and C
three. And you get the pawn chain from the
game, except you get a much improved version
for Black. This is a better version than
what Black had in the game because the
knight goes out to C six, it
doesn't go out to D seven, which is a
terrible square. It's a dead end square.
The knight has to go out to C six here, and
Black puts immediate pressure on the D four
pawn. You can see how different this is from
the game continuation, and White is unable
to squeeze in, uh, F four.
This is what I meant.
There is also a line of the French knight, C
three, called the Winauer Bishop Before, and
a kind of similar structure arises
in the main line of the Winauer, E five, C
five, A three, and then we
often have a trade. This position
is incredibly well studied. And again,
you have this kind of situation where
White is a pawn chain and Black is
attacking either the base of it or the
middle of it with its pawns and pieces.
Okay, in the game continuation, it's
a much inferior version for Black
because this knight is placed on a horrible
square, and Black has lost a tempo playing C
six and C five.   So
queen C seven, I think is decent. We got our
bishop out to D three,   E six, F.
Uh, four, I think, is pretty sensible.
I think our opponent played sensibly for a
while. G six. Pretty
normal move. We got our night
out.      They
got their night out. We brought
our bishop out. The night went to
F five, and you want to
avoid taking on F five
prematurely. I don't like the idea of
giving up the LightSquared bishop
until it's sort of absolutely
necessary. You can play the move. Bishop
takes F five at any moment. So
rushing a move like that is just
completely senseless. And the bishop on D
three is quite a nicely placed piece.
So does C Four
not benefit Black? I think C four might even
be the best way for Black to
handle this position.   I actually think
that with the light squares closed
down, this move makes a lot more
sense    because a position
like this is quite bad for Black. First of
all, because of what I pointed out earlier,
the fact that a lot of the dark squares on
the king side are quite weak, and we can
bring our bishop to age four. But the second
reason is that white actually holds a lot of
the cars on the Queen side. A lot of
people are afraid of this type of
attack, but it's not very dangerous
when you don't have your pieces to
support the pawn storm.   So,
like, Black, uh, can bring the pond to b
four. Big deal. What is black
actually threatening? Not really.
Nothing, really, because c three is nicely
protected, and we can already start trying
to checkmate Black on the other side of the
board. With queen h five a devastating
threat. And you can see how good this
knight is. H six, by the way,
there's 96 a worthy
pattern to know. This is mate.
So no matter what black does on the
Queen side, our play on the king side is
going to be superior. So that's just
one example of why c four is not very
effective. You can, of course, also drop
the bishop back and again after b
five, you castle. And if Black
plays b four, this could actually
benefit White. I would even
consider taking on B four and bringing
the night out, because the pawn on B four is
so well protected by the minor
pieces in the Queen that we can afford to
give up its support in service of
a better developing square for the night.
Later on, you could also play b
three and work on opening the Queen's
side. So Hess always says that the
side that controls the pawn breaks
usually has the advantage. And
in this case, even though it may appear
that black has a nice pawn chain, black has
no pawn breaks. White is the one
who can push pawns on both sides
of the board and essentially open up
the position whenever he pleases to do
that.   That's a lot of words,
but hopefully that explanation made
sense.     So c
four might have been the way for black to
play. Of course, Black definitely
in the game, regretted not playing C four
because we ended up being the ones to play C
four.    So
we've got our pieces out, and I think
queen b six is really the beginning of the
end. I think after we played C
four,   black's position
completely evaporates.
So probably in retrospect, black
should have, in fact, played C four. And
again, we can take on, um, f five. And a
very good move here is actually to play a
four and prevent Black from playing b five
altogether.  Then we can play
our old idea, bishop h four and
carve out the dark squares on the kingside.
Black has just no active prospects here at
all or immediately. Bishop h
four also makes a lot of sense. This is the
engine recommendation.
So this type of
position   is horrible because this other
night is coming out to G
five, a very powerful
outpost. And again, although Black has more
space on the Queen's side. White is the one
who holds the main pawn break, which is the
move B three, to open up potentially even
the C file or the A file.
So     C Four was
maybe the lesser evil. And I want
to show you   my
inspiration for the move C Four, because I
came across a game quite recently that
I thought was pretty sick,  played
in the French Championship.     All
right. This is MVL against Degrade.
Degrade is a former French
champion, very strong grandmaster. I've
played him multiple times.   Let me replay
the first moves really, really quickly.
So this was a caro khan? I'm going to skip
the theory. The theory is not that
interesting, but you can recognize the
structure. And the critical position was
reached in this position.
So Black has this
very typical French type pressure
on D four. And it actually seems
like black has more attackers on D Four than
White could even, hypothetically, have
defenders, which is true.
But watch what MBL does. He
plays this seemingly unconcerned move
92. Not like, what, uh, the hell
is he doing? Is closing down his bishop.
And Degrade just takes on D four.
And you might imagine that White has
misplayed the opening. Right. White's lost
the main center pawn.  What
does MBL come up with in this
position? It's a brilliant sequence.
Turns out the black's pieces are so
undeveloped that if White can find
any way to rip open the
center, white's just going to have
tremendous attacking potential.
It's too early for knight takes G
six because you reach a dead end. You
don't have enough pieces in the attack.
As, uh, tempting as it is to sack on G
six, it's premature. You just
don't have firepower.
You have one piece at most. C four is
correct. And VL plays C
four,   and he puts
another attacker on the D five. Bond.
Black has to give away the C four
square for White's knight. But the
brilliant move comes after queen C seven.
It does still look like Black is
more or less holding on, but in fact,
this is already the beginning of the end.
The rook is X raying the king.
So you might be very tempted by Nike
six check. Uh, but this,
while an interesting pawn
sacrifice, doesn't seem to produce anything
concrete. But how do we set it up?   We
set it up with knight to D five. Very nice.
Sacking the knight. And if what, black takes
the knight to six is devastating, because
here it's a discover check
and White wins the queen. And if king
E Seven, then bishop E five and Black's king
is driven out and check mated,
then the queen gets out.
There's this very beautiful mate,
but these lines are ridiculously
one sided. If F six, then
White takes it and drops the bishop
back to, uh, F four, winning the queen.
So MVL could not or
DeGrave didn't take it. But that allowed
the knight to infiltrate b six. Then the
bishop came out and this game lasts like
three more moves. MVL brings all of his
pieces out and Degrade
resigned  in, uh, this position
without awaiting White's next
move, which I think is Knight takes
D seven. Then it takes C
three and Bishop takes G six, winning
all of the pieces on the board. So
that's how one side of this game was and
how powerful these C four ideas can be.
Okay, so now let's go back
to the, uh, speedrun game.
And C four is, as
I refer to it,
one type of category of plans
and closed positions, which is just to
reopen the position.   The other
category is to keep the center closed
and kind of worm your way around the center
and play on the flanks.   This is kind of
category one. And C four is just incredibly
powerful. The engine confirms it. By the
way, this is crushing.
Queen takes B two, we play
CD, we play Bishop F
five, and we play DC. Just completing
our plan. Maybe not the best way
to play. In fact, if you run this
into an engine, the engine will often
give these sort of slow moves,
these weirdly slow moves.
So here, for instance, the recommendation is
A four, which actually crossed my
mind. The idea is to play A five
and cut off the queen's escape route.
And if CD, then
you can play Bishop F five and then
CD.   And in this
position, even Knight takes D four as
crushing because the queen is suddenly in a
lot of trouble. The, ah, knight's getting
into B five.   So it's kind of a
move that grabs space. It's almost a waiting
move because Black literally has no
good way to resolve the central
tension. And in the event of a
trade like this, white brings the other
night out to F three. This pawn and A four
could act as a very nice little push for the
attack.
Yeah, it's like plus two at this moment.
It's like plus two. So we
decided on a more primitive approach, just
sort of fully opening the center.
And I will admit that after Bishop D
four, Queen A three, E six,
there was a move that I had missed from a
distance. And this was literally the only
move for Black to play. This is the move F
six. This was forced. Black had to keep
the center as closed as
possible because after rook G eight, there
is nothing left to talk about. This is just
absolute and total devastation.
But if Black had played F
six despite the sort of
flimsy appearance of Black's position, it's
not easy for us to actually crash
through. In fact, I think that White needs
to be quite careful here not to be worse.
I like the look of the move knight to
H four attacking F, uh five.
And if Bishop takes E
six, then we can sneak the knight into G
six, exploiting some of the weak
squares on the king side
to chip away at Black's defensive
construction.    And
then we can play 97. And if
we can bring the king out, then we
actually have this move, queen to f three,
incredibly strong move   with the
idea of the intermezzo on c
five.
So    this is all
very, very hard to defend, but if you flip
on the engine, it gives some sort of weird
engine move. Queen D three, bishop drops
back    94. I mean, things
do get pretty messy
here. Ultimately you get some sort of
a liquidation in an endgame and
white is slightly better,   but
black holds on with bishop takes
d six.
So f six, believe it or
not, it does appear and somebody should
run the engine here at a higher depth to
find out the truth. But f six
might have kept Black very much in the game
position, might be objectively about equal.
So you could say
that   the strategy that
we started with bishop takes f five
was a small, was maybe not a big
mistake, but a small mistake
apparently. Here we also could have
played a move like rook to B one,
sacking a second pawn,
and now queen C one,
another typical engine idea.
And now rook a one traps the
queen. So the idea again is to play
against black's queen, force it
back, but now we can play
DC. That's the other reason we put the queen
on c one to protect the c five one.
So I think it's a good
idea to analyze with engines in
these types of positions because
you get a better sense of really cool ideas
that are available that you could apply at a
later point.
So some people were suggesting e
six, and I think it is an
interesting pawn sack if you follow it up
with rookie one just attacking e
six and trying to open up the e file,
which is one of the biggest things that
white can do for his attack. But I wasn't
totally sure. After night f six, the pawn
is defended, but now you
also get the juicy e five square. So
definitely this would be an excellent
way for white to play. Here there is
a ridiculous tactic, knight
DC four,   and after
the trade, the queen is trapped
because if queen b four,
then rugby one, queen c three, rugby
three traps the queen   of queen b five,
there's a fork. If queen c
three, there's the quiet or ah rug c
one,   rugby one
and rugby three traps the
queen. So just an assortment of
ridiculous ideas. Black actually has to
go queen b five here and
then take on d six with the knight and black
gets three pieces for the queen. But white
should still be better because all of
black's pieces are totally
discombobulated and the king side is quite
weak.   So   e
six was a very interesting
alternative, just sacking the pond
and opening up the center,
an idea that you do see in a lot of
different openings in the Perk. You see
that often    in the Perk
and the modern in the bishops e four
lines. There's a lot of lines
here,    and I'm giving you just
an abstraction
where, like, you drive the pawn up
to east. I guess this is not a sacrifice,
but it's the same type of idea. You're just
blasting open the center, you're throwing
the grenade in, and then you're picking it
up later. In many cases,
um,    in any
case,    our
opponent made a grave error with
rookie g eight. This just served
us up with a very
straightforward way to get the king
into the open with all of our
pieces participating.
If king e eight here, then I would have
taken    and now
I like the look of a quiet move like
rook eight to c one, just bringing another
piece into the attack, as I had discussed
earlier.   And now for, for example,
queen f seven is already winning
because you have the additional check on c
six   and takes. And
now takes. That's the beauty
of putting a rook on c one. You never know
when it's going to serve you well,
but it's never going to hurt to
bring another piece into the attack.
This was nominally more
resilient, I think. Here the game
is largely over and our
opponent did resign what I thought
was a little bit prematurely, but the
position is just disgusting. And as I had
shown after bishop d seven, I
think the simplest is to go rook AC
one   and then to play a move
like knight to g six or even without rook AC
one, you could just go night g six straight
away. And the game is
over. The game is over
because   everything is hanging.
Black has no
ability to defend anything.
This is just checkmate. I mean,
just look at this position. Literally, we're
attacking everything. We can go rugby one,
we can go rookie one.
There's many ways to win, but
these types of moves which just pick
off a ton of material,
are oftentimes the most clinical and the
least risky.
So you could dig
around here on your own if you want a better
kind of sense of why this is
as lost as it is. But
you should just understand that it's
not even the threat of checkmate.
White is not threatening checkmate here.
It's just that the general nature of black's
pieces makes the position totally
indefensible. Okay, so
another successful fantasy
outing.   Very nice. We're building
up quite a    quite
a few nice games in the fantasy.
Hope you enjoyed
these I'm also losing my voice. Hope you
enjoyed these games games. Hope you enjoyed
the speedrun today and hopefully see you
tomorrow for title Tuesday. Bye.